hello everyone I am Isabelle Zimmerman I
work for a company called posit
um if you're wondering where you have
heard that before uh there was a talk
from my colleague Hadley Wickham
yesterday
um he was one of uh the Keynotes uh we
are all about R and Python and thinking
about multilingual teams and how to make
uh their lives easier uh I specifically
work with ML Ops and I kind of I started
my career um as a software engineer
slash data scientist and I worked a lot
um deploying models with kubernetes of
course if you know anything about
kubernetes it's a little frustrating so
I decided to take out some of my like
kubernetes stress with teaching my dog
silly tricks
and the first trick I taught um was to
teach him to sit and what I first taught
him to sit you know I call him to stand
right in front of me and I tell him to
sit and he figures it out and I give him
a treat
but then I started taking him on walks
and bringing him out into the real world
um and you know he's walking next to me
on my side and I would tell him to sit
and he had no idea what I meant and of
course the data scientist me is like oh
I I overfit my model I over trained my
dog
um because he realized that I realized
that I'd only ever trained him to sit
like in front of me never off to the
side
and you know that's that's kind of a
hard lesson for data scientists to learn
but all I knew was I was training for
the right outcome
um to sit and in my cozy living room it
totally made sense
um and it worked really well uh he he
knew my task and he would sit on command
but when we went out into the real world
on our silly little walks
um there was a new set of challenges and
he behaved differently I realized as I
need to you know expand my tool set
um and expand my mindset for how to
train my dog
but this is not a dog training
conference
um so I'll tell you this the real world
value of models
um oftentimes comes from integrating
them into some larger ecosystem
so my advice for you is to bring your
model on a walk uh you can learn to
operationalize a model using practices
called ml Ops
and ml Ops is a set of practices to
deploy and maintain machine learning
models in production reliably and
efficiently
and these practices can be hard
especially with the kubernetes-based
models I had started out with I felt
like a lot of the tools that I was using
I had to be kind of a cloud architect as
well as a data scientist
and I don't think that data scientists
should be oblivious to everything in the
devops OR nlops world but there's
definitely a space for tools that help
data scientists more effectively
communicate with their I.T or devops
teams
um these tools can still feel ergonomic
for data scientists
so I actually changed career paths
um and a package called fediver was made
uh vetiver is an mlops tool for data
scientists uh specifically to help them
um version Monitor and deploy models in
production
um in both R and python
and we thought this was really important
um to build a tool like this because
when you start learning about data
science you see an image that looks
something like this you collect data you
understand and clean your data if you're
using R that's with tools like the Tidy
verse or data table if you're using
python that's using tools like pandas or
numpy or Suba
and then you get to training and
evaluating your model once again in R
you're using tools like tidy models or
in Python psychic learn Pi torch
and these
um these different tools have best
practices built in in a really ergonomic
way uh
if you're a data scientist you write
code that looks probably something like
this
you're going to load in your data and
you know select columns or whatever but
in almost every data science script you
have a line at the top that sets the
random scene for reproducibility of your
model and this feels good people know
how to use it they know it's a best
practice of data science
when you get to training your model you
split into test and training sets so
you're not giving your model the answers
to the questions you're about to ask it
beforehand
and this is built into the tools we use
and it feels good and it's ergonomic and
we know that this is a best practice
and then you get into the actual like
modeling part of your code
and you think about the right future
engineering for the job and you think
about how to train your model
um and maybe putting these together in a
pipeline
um
to make sure that they're all you know
organized and running in the right uh
right order and this feels ergonomic and
it's part of the tools you're using
but oftentimes this is where you start
um you know the data science code
but then you realize that working with a
larger team there's there's more to data
science than training models you have to
think about how you're sharing these
models with others that's not emailing
um joblib files back and forth
you have to think about
um maybe this needs to be integrated
into a larger application how are you
going to get the model from your local
environment to there
and how do you make sure that this model
is still performing well a month from
now or even a week from now and you
realize that these ergonomic practices
and the tools that you love to use
aren't quite enough
and that's where machine learning
operations comes in
vetiver the project I work on
um is to monitor version and deploy
models
um specifically to help complete that
Circle
so what are some pieces used in mlops
most open source projects fall into one
or maybe multiple of these orchestration
experiment tracking versioning serving
and monitoring pieces things like
orchestration are going to put your
models in larger pipelines experiment
tracking is going to make sure all the
pieces that are going into the model are
organized versioning serving and
monitoring will go into a little bit
deeper right now
so if that ever helps with versioning
um serving and monitoring
and when people think about versioning a
lot of times you're thinking about git
and we actually version a lot of things
and mostly very badly
if you think about you know you're
making a model
um and you you train it
um you've started out you saved it as
model doing a little bit more work with
it you have model final
and you feel pretty good
um but maybe you get new data or you
want to try out a new algorithm and it
works better
and then you realize there's actually
another iteration and you can see how
this
um beta science workflow of versioning
locally might not be the right fit
um we can see that this uh model final
model final final doesn't scale for one
model let alone tens or hundreds of
models
it would be really nice you know if
we're thinking about what we want out of
versioning if these could all live in a
central location
um that we can access but also maybe our
teammates
uh and especially if they could load
right into memory and maybe have a
little bit more context where I don't
have to guess what model file really
means
and there's actually a secret weapon
that the project I work on vetiver uses
um and this is another open source
Library called pins and pins is also
available in Python and R and it helps
you organize and store your models
and it does this by creating a board
so the mental model for for a board is
maybe to
um like think of it's a place for your
models and then you can pin your models
onto your board
so it's creating a place for models to
be stored we can see here this is a
temporary board
um but this could also be board
underscore S3 Azure GCS for Google Cloud
Storage or connect which is posits
homegrown Pro product
so now that we have a space for our
model to go we can create a vetiver
model object so this is a Deployable
model object because there's actually a
lot of information that you have at
training time
um that you can store that's useful from
your model later here all we're going to
put in is our random Forest pipeline we
made before and we're going to get a bit
a name ads
from there we can vetiver pin write our
temporary board
um we're going to put our vetiver model
V onto the temporary board
and with that uh we have
some more context as well
um not only is this organized within the
board for us automatically uh we can see
a description of the model we can see
the size of it
um what kind of file it is and some
other required packages
if we wanted to take this a step further
we could even give our model more
context so we could save a tiny little
piece of our training data to better
debug when things go wrong in production
if you uh think about it like a puzzle
it's a lot easier to make a puzzle when
you know what the finished product is
supposed to look like and this is
essentially giving that finished product
to our model
and it's pretty easy to add this in this
is the same line of code before but we
just have one more argument p-type data
for Prototype data and we're going to
give it our extreme
but we want to also think more
holistically about tracking inversioning
models and there's the idea of something
called a model card and model cards are
to make sure you're not only making good
statistical models but good ethical
models that you've thought really wholly
about uh model cards are kind of like
recipes
um you know you never know as much about
your cake as like oh this this batter is
a little watery or something like that
then when you're making it model cards
use that same mental model
um they want to make sure that you can
have a designated place to write down
all the information you know when
training your model that you can look
back at later so that summary statistics
that's General documentation as well as
nods to fairness
so we saw this line of code earlier as
well
um better for pen right our V vetiver
model onto our model board
but there's actually a little
informative message that pops up after
and you can read the informative message
or you can do what every software
engineer does and just copy and paste
the code and run it and see what happens
um this vetiver.model card
and when you run this vetiver.model card
there's a quarto document that is
generated and quarto is a flavor of
markdown that is used for documentation
that you can actually run Live code in
my slides were made in quarto
um as well as my blog is made in quarto
if you're interested in learning more
tomorrow there is a talk on Corto by my
colleague Tom mock
um to explore the wonderful world of
this new tool
so if you open up your quarto card
um you can see there's uh some
information that's automatically
generated for you
and that's things like
um you know it's a psychic learn
pipeline it's a model using four
features here's when the model was
created
um and if you scroll down
there's also uh some information on that
input data prototype so this model has
got four features looking at houses as
well as a quantitative analysis looking
at things like mean absolute error means
squared error
and so on
and if you scroll all the way to the end
there's also places for you to document
ethical considerations that you have and
caveats and recommendations
um that you've uncovered while training
this model
and of course if you don't really have
information for either of these off the
top of your head
it's important to keep these on the
model card because imprecise or
incomplete information is better than
none at all
um my dad had always told me growing up
that if you haven't written it down you
haven't thought it out and model cards
are a great place for you to write out
all of the things that you've been
thinking about at training time for your
model
so we know about the beginning of this
life cycle and we know about what
versioning a model is and so what
happens when we have to deploy it
so deployment means a lot of different
things for a lot of different people uh
but the way that our team has uh defined
it as is bringing a model off a local
um laptop into some sort of other
architecture
we do this by creating a rest API
endpoint it makes your software engineer
friends happy because they are pretty
robust and testable and it makes your
data scientists happy because there's a
lot of great tools to help you spin them
up and maintain them
to do this with vetiver if you want to
run an API locally uh our vetiver model
named V from earlier can be put into a
vetiver API and you can run it
but of course the end goal of this is to
not have a local API endpoint so if you
were to want to deploy this onto our pro
products are which is connect you could
set up a connect server and then just
send it the model board the name of your
model
um and then the specific version that
you'd like to deploy and it will do the
rest of the work for you
if you're looking to
um move this into maybe a Docker file or
anywhere that ingests stalker files such
as AWS or Azure or Google Cloud Storage
or Google Cloud platform
uh you can do this in two different
steps first is to write out an app.pi
file as long as you're giving your board
and pin name to this this function it
will generate this app.pi file for you
um and get you at least most of the way
there
and then
you can write out a Docker file and send
in the app.pi file that you have just
created and then this Docker file will
be written out for you um that's usable
out of the box but that you can also
edit to customize for your own
deployment
and that's what deployment looks like
using vetiver
um these helper functions are really
made to make it feel accessible to get
this model off your laptop or at least
to have a Docker file in hand to pass
off to somebody else
now once your model is off your laptop a
data scientist's work is not done
and monitoring means something unique in
this context we're not necessarily
monitoring
um
things like CPU usage or runtime here
we're specifically looking at the
statistical properties of the input data
or predictions
and vetiver helps this out with a few
helper functions I won't go too deep
into them right now but it essentially
will help you compute metrics over
certain rolling window time frames that
you specify here it'll be for one week
um you can help it'll help you pin your
metrics especially if you get into that
awkward situation where some of the
dates overlap
um vetiver pin metrics will sort that
out for you overwrite with the newest
data if necessary
and then finally vetiver also helps you
plot your metrics
um in the same format that is coming out
of vetiver compute metrics uh to get
kind of an out of the box quick uh peek
into how your
model is performing
and this is really important to track if
you are not monitoring your model you
are oblivious to model decay
and of course that makes sense you you
need some data to make sure you're doing
the right thing but this is especially
important
because
um models break quietly uh they'll
continue to run and really just proudly
give you very wrong answers
um even if your accuracy is like zero
percent
whereas on the other side you know
applications will often give you big red
X's models will continue to give you bad
answers so if you're not monitoring your
model you are oblivious to this decay
okay
and that has completed our cycle in a
very fast way we have gone over
versioning a model deploying a model and
monitoring the model
but if we think about vetiver as a whole
why should I be excited about vetiver
well why am I excited about fediver I
think the first piece of this is
composability I've shown you some strong
building blocks of vetiver API and
vetiver model
um that are pretty simple to use right
out of the box but they're also
composable within themselves to add new
endpoints to your API or to make more
complex models or custom models
so not only is it uh composable with
itself internally it's also composable
with other the larger ecosystem so
externally
and this is because uh vetiver is built
on really tested tools by the community
it's built on things like Fast API and
pedantic and there's such a community
around these different tools that you
can leverage all of the fun and amazing
other projects that people have created
the other reason to be excited about
fediver is the ergonomics it feels good
to use it's pretty lightweight and it
works with the tools that you like to
use it's supposed to feel like a really
natural extension of the data science
workflow that you're already using
so overall vetiver helps you version
deploy and monitor models in a
composable and ergonomic way
thank you all for joining me here today
um it has been my pleasure to present
for you all
thank you as for your uh presentation uh
at this point uh if anybody has any
comments uh please put it into
uh the uh your YouTube comment section
and we will uh bring it up here
um in the meantime uh
I just wanted to say I I think uh uh
vetiver is definitely filling a very
important Gap in the current data
science ecosystem I feel like uh this
year we've seen a lot more talks
compared to last year and the year
before on sort of uh how to uh do the
monitoring like whether it is
uh uh like maybe maybe doing better
testing to to make sure uh that the
model doesn't pay uh or whether it is a
um full solution uh like what you guys
have here
so thank you very much
it's my my pleasure I think we've we've
taken a lot of Knowledge from Python and
together
hello sorry
we have just taken a lot of Knowledge
from this these different ecosystems
um we we've talked to a lot of data
scientists and tried to understand
really what what are they looking for
and what do they want
um from a ml op solution and a lot of
that was I like my workflow the way it
is can I just have something that adds
on to it
um there's a lot of different solutions
that maybe you have to really declare
something early on
um and change your workflow so this felt
like the right way to go for us to help
serve our customers and the needs that
we had heard
uh so we have a couple questions uh
let's start with the first one uh seems
like Federer is built on top of many
dependencies isn't it hard to manage
them all
so this is okay I'll try to not get too
deep into the Weeds on this one this was
a really fun task for my team and I
um because it's hard you know if you're
deploying a psychic learn model you
don't want to have to download a
framework that has pi torch installed
and like stats models installed and all
of these other things so you know how do
you
um make sure you don't bloat your your
own project but also serve so many
different people
um and we're able to do that with
something called single dispatch
um so we actually can like break things
down and you only install what you need
uh
the dependencies at our core that
um
that we do have to manage are things
like Fast API and pedantic uh which a
lot of packages have a lot of
dependencies so these are manageable and
they're pretty lightweight
um the where things really do get
difficult is when you're trying to
manage multiple
um
machine learning model platforms at once
um so we were able to break those apart
if you ever want to like chat about how
weird and funky this is I would love to
hop on Discord
um and chat with you about that it was
so cool
cool uh thank you and just as a reminder
there is on Discord a uh Channel called
Talk stash discussions uh which Isabel
and other speakers will be monitoring
um
question from Patrick uh it looks like
Federer is a decentralized version of
some of these other platforms that
require spinning up and on-prem or a
Cloud Server to track this stuff is that
true
so
let me make sure I answer this correctly
uh to have something that is
shareable with your larger team A lot of
times the right tool is to be on Prem or
in a Cloud Server that's using Docker
files so vetiver is able to bring your
model onto those different places as
well I think one of the the exciting
things that we like to play around with
with vetiver is it makes it really easy
to spin things up locally so that's
might be where you're feeling this
decentralized bit and that's really
important because a lot of times when
you're testing or like development
versions are very different from what
your deployed versions feel like things
break very quickly
um so being able to like quickly rapidly
prototype a small API and then scale it
safely is something that that ever
focuses on a lot
um so yes it can be easy to put up
locally in a really decentralized way
but it also makes it easy to ship it to
an on-prem or Cloud Server instance
and a question from Neil how does
vetiver compare with ML flow when would
you prefer one over the other
Ops tools out there and mlflow is one
that we we've looked at a lot and what
they've done really well is they have a
lot of investment into experiment
tracking
um so if you are looking to track all of
the hyper parameters that you've used
when training your model like every
single time you've trained your model
that's something that mlflow does very
very well so if you're looking for
experiment tracking I think that's a
good place to go
um if you're looking for making apis
quickly and safely I think that's where
vetiver shines kind of for the reasons I
just mentioned
um because it is
like three lines of code to do a very
simple
um spit up a model with an API so I'd
say if you're looking for experiment
tracking ml flow is a great place to
start if you're looking for deployment
of apis that ever might be your better
option